The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
morning everyone.
Morning.
Let's get started.
So the second of two
lectures on numerics.
Last time we had this
motivating question
of finding the millionth
digit of the square root of 2,
or the square root
of quantities that
end up becoming irrational.
And we talked about
high-precision arithmetic,
and we use Newton's method
to compute the square roots.
You saw a demo of
computing square roots,
but there's a few
things missing.
We don't quite know how
to do division, which
is required for the
Newton's method,
and we didn't really talk at
all about algorithmic complexity
beyond talking about the
complexity of multiplication.
So multiplication is a
primitive that at this point
we know how to do in a
couple of different ways,
including the naive
order n squared
algorithm and the
Karatsuba algorithm,
which is something
like n raised to 1.58.
But how many times
is multiplication
called when you
compute square roots?
In fact, multiplication
is called
when you call the
division operator
when you compute square roots.
So there's really two levels
off a computation going on here
and we need to open this
up, and look at in detail,
and figure out what our overall
algorithmic complexity is.
So that's really the
meat of today's lecture.
Getting to the
point where we know
what we have with respect
to asymptotic complexity
of computing the square
root of a number.
So let me start with a review
of what we covered last time.
We decided that we wanted
the millionth digit
of square root of 2.
And the way we're
going to do this
is by working with integers
and computing the floor,
since we needed to be an
integer, of 2 times 10 raised
to 2d, where d is the number
of digits of precision.
N over there.
So we'll take a look
at an example or two
here as to how this
works with integers.
But what we do is compute
essentially the floor
of some quantity a, the square
root of some quantity a,
via Newton's method.
And the way Newton's
method works
is you go through an iteration.
You start with x0 being one,
which is your initial guess,
and compute xi plus 1 equals
xi plus a divided by xi over 2.
And as you can see,
this requires division,
because we're computing
a divided by xi.
That's the outer
Newton iteration.
And I said a couple
of things that's said
you are going to have a
quadratic rate of convergence.
The precision with respect
to the number of digits
is going to increase by a
factor of 2 every iteration.
And so if you started out
with one digit of precision,
you go to two, then
four, eight, et cetera.
And so that's a
geometric progression.
And that means that
we're going to have
a logarithmic number of
iterations, which is nice.
And we were all happy about
that, and you believed me.
I gave you an example and
it looked pretty good,
but didn't really prove anything
about the rate of convergence.
What I'd like to do now is
take a look at this particular
iterative computation, where
we're computing xi plus 1 given
xi , and argue
that this, in fact,
has a quadratic
rate of convergence.
So you can think
of this as doing
an error analysis
of Newton's method.
And let's say that xn equals
square root of a 1 plus epsilon
n, where epsilon may be
positive or negative.
So we have an error
associated with xn
in the n-th iteration with
respect to what we want,
which is the square root of a.
And it's off by something.
It may be a large
quantity in the beginning.
We want to show
convergence, so obviously we
want epsilon n, as n
becomes large, do tend to 0.
How fast does this approach 0?
That's the question.
And so if you take this equation
and plug this into that,
and say, what is xn plus 1?
xn plus 1 would be square root
of a times 1 plus epsilon n
plus a divided by square
root of a 1 plus epsilon
n divided by 2.
Just plugging it
in, the value of xn.
And then some a couple of steps
of algebraic simplification,
you can pull out the
square root of a here,
then you have 1
plus epsilon n, 1
divided by 1 plus
epsilon n over here.
The whole thing divided by 2.
And if you keep going-- there's
one step that I'm skipping here
in terms of
simplification, but let
me write this last result out.
Which is xn plus 1 is
square root of a times 1
plus epsilon n squared
divided by 2 times 1
plus epsilon n
down at the bottom.
So what do we have here in
terms of the overall observation
for epsilon n plus 1,
which is the error in the n
plus 1-th iteration given
that you have an epsilon n
error in the n-th iteration?
You have a relationship like
so where epsilon n plus 1
is related to epsilon
n whole square.
And this part here,
as n becomes large,
epsilon n is going
to go to 0 assuming
a decent initial guess.
And so you can say that
this is essentially
1, which means you have this
quadratic rate of convergence
where the error, which
is a small quantity,
is getting squared
at every iteration.
And so if you have
something like a 0.01 error
at the beginning for
epsilon n, epsilon n squared
is going to be 0.0001.
So that's where you get the
quadratic rate of convergence.
So it really comes from this
relationship, the relationship
epsilon n squared
to epsilon n plus 1,
Any questions about this?
Great.
So if you have the quadratic
rate of convergence,
if you want to go to d digits
of precision like I have here,
you can argue that you
need to log d iterations.
So that's kind of nice, you
have a logarithmic number
of iterations.
I'm going to get back to that.
There's one little
subtlety that is associated
with asymptotic analysis
that goes beyond simply
the number of
iterations that you have
and the digits of precision.
But so far so good.
We're happy with this
logarithmic number
of iterations.
And if we can now compute the
complexity of the division,
then obviously we need
an algorithm for that.
But if you have an
algorithm and we figure out
what the complexity of
the division algorithm is,
then we have complexity
for the square root of 2
or square root of a
using Newton's method.
So just justified what I
said last time with respect
to quadratic rate
of convergence.
And then we talked about
multiplication last time.
I want to revisit that.
You have multiplication
algorithms,
and we want to be able to
multiply d digit numbers.
And the naive algorithm.
And you could imagine
doing divide and conquer.
So you take x1,
x0; y1, y0 where x1
is the most
significant half of x.
You're trying to
multiply x times y.
And same thing for y1 and y0.
So each of these will have
d by 2, digits of precision.
And if you implement
the naive algorithm that
looks like tn equals 4
tn by 2 plus theta n,
you end up with theta n
squared complexity out
so you have to do four
multiplications corresponding
to x1 times Y1 x1
times y0, et cetera.
And at each level in
the recursive tree,
you're breaking things down
by a factor of 2 respect
to the digits of
precision that you
need to multiply on as
you're going down the tree.
And this is the four
multiplications.
You get your theta n
squared complexity.
This gentleman by
the name of Karatsuba
recognized that you could play
a few mathematical tricks, which
I won't go over
again, but reduce
to three multiplications.
And you do a few more
additions, but given
that the additions have
theta n complexity,
the recurrence relationship
turns into tn equals 3t of n
over 2 plus theta n.
And this ends up having
1.58 dot dot dot complexity.
No reason to stop with breaking
things up into two parts.
You could imagine
generalizing Karatsuba
and people have done this.
Two different researchers,
Toom and Cook,
generalized Karatsuba
for the case
where k is greater than
or equal to 2, where
you're breaking it into k parts.
So the Toom-Cook 2 algorithm
is basically Karatsuba,
but you have Toom 3,
Toom 4, and so on.
And I'm not going to give
you a lot of details on this.
We don't expect you to work
on this, at least in 6006.
But just to give you a
sense of what happens,
the Toom 3 method, or
the Toom-Cook 3 method,
breaks and number
up into three parts.
So each of these would have
d by 3 digits of precision.
So this is what you're
starting out with.
You're starting out
with a d digit number.
But the very first level
of recursion, you're
going to break things up
into three xi numbers that
are d by 3 digits long.
Same thing for y.
And if you did a naive
multiplication of this,
how many multiplications
do I need?
If I just forget about
any mathematical tricks,
if I just tried to
multiply these things out,
how many d by 3 by d by 3
multiplications do I need?
AUDIENCE: Nine.
PROFESSOR: Nine.
So if you can beat nine
using mathematical tricks,
you have a better divide
and conquer algorithm.
And it turns out that Toom 3
plays some arithmetic games
and ends up with a
recurrence relationship that
looks like this.
Where you reduce the nine
multiplications down to five.
So that's a win.
And that ends up being
theta of n raised to what?
Someone?
Someone loudly.
Log--
AUDIENCE: Base 3.
PROFESSOR: Log
with a base 3 of 5.
Another irrational number.
And this ends up being
n raised to 1.465.
So you won.
If you use Toom 3, assuming
the constants worked out--
and Victor can say
a little bit more
about that, because we're having
a little trouble justifying
this particular
problem set question
that we want to give you, given
the constant factors involved.
So the issue really
here is this is correct.
It's n raised to 1.46.
That's n raised to 1.5.
And then the naive
algorithm is n square.
But how big does n
have to be in order
for the n raised
to 1.58 algorithm
to beat the n square
algorithm, and for the n raised
to 1.46 algorithm
to beat the n raised
to 1.58 algorithm, et cetera.
And it turns out n needs
to be really, really large
if you implement
these in Python.
So if you're having a
little trouble here,
giving you this
pristine problem set
that you can go off and
learn about multiplication,
and also appreciate
asymptotic complexity.
So that's a bit of a catch-22.
Anyway, for the purposes
of theory, this is great.
It turns people have
done even better.
Multiplication is just this
obviously incredibly important
primitive that you
would need for doing
any reasonable computation.
And so people have worked on
using things like fast Fourier
transforms and other
techniques improve
the complexity of
multiplication.
And best scheme
until a few years
ago was this scheme called
Schonhage-Strassen scheme,
which is almost
linear in complexity.
It's n log n log log n time.
And this uses the fast
Fourier transform, FFT.
And you can play with
all of these things.
You can play with Karatsuba
the naive algorithm, Toom 3,
et cetera in the gmpy
package in Python.
And you can see as to
what the value of n
needs to be in order for
one of these algorithms
to beat the other.
This is not
something that you're
going to do specifically
in the problem set,
but I say that as an aside.
These algorithms
are implemented,
and they're used in real life.
Eric?
ERIC: It may be worth
mentioning that Python itself
for long integers
uses Karatsuba.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so Python
uses-- beyond a certain n,
you are going to
have decisions that
are made within the package.
And Python shifts to Karatsuba
after n becomes large.
But if n is small,
then it's going
to run the naive algorithm.
Now if you write your
own multiplication,
you can do whatever you want.
You can have your own
adaptive scheme, assuming you
have many of these
algorithms implemented,
or you're calling them
using the gmpy package.
So lastly, this looked
pretty good for a while.
And from a
theoretical standpoint
there was a breakthrough.
Guy by the name of Furer came
up with this algorithm that
is n log n-- and let me write
this carefully-- 2 raised
big O-- that's an upper
bound-- of log star n.
That makes sense?
No.
I'll have to explain it.
OK, so what does this mean?
This part is clear.
This is like sorting.
It doesn't need to really use
sorting, but that's n log n.
And then you have this 2
raised to big O log star n.
I need to define
what log star n is.
And log star n is what's called
the iterative algorithm--
logarithm, rather.
I guess it's an
iterative algorithm,
but it computes logs.
And the iterative
logarithm is the number
of times log needs to be
applied to get a result that
is less than or equal to 1.
So this thing really cuts
you down to size really fast.
So it doesn't matter.
You could be a 10 raised
to 24, or 2 raised to 50,
let's say, if you were
doing binary logs.
And in the very first iteration
you go down to 50, right?
And then you take a log of
50 and you go down to about 7
or something.
And then you take the log of 7.
And if you're talking
about base 2, like we were,
you're down to less than 3.
And so four or five
iterations, you're
down to less than or equal to 1.
And that's what log
star n computes.
It's not the logarithm as
much as the number of times
so you have to apply log to
get the result that's less than
or equal to 1.
So you have these giant numbers,
and it's only like five,
six, eight times do you apply
log and you're down to one.
So for all practical
purposes, you can think of--
and this is upper bound--
you can think of this,
even though this is 2
raised to something,
it's 2 raised to a
pretty small number.
2 raised to 10,
that would be 1,000.
And so from an asymptotic
complexity standpoint,
this is the winner.
From a practical standpoint,
Schonhage-Strassen
is really what you
probably want to use
when n becomes very
large, to the billions
and so on and so forth.
And as of now, to the
best of my knowledge
this hasn't been implemented
in the gmpy package.
So if you actually want to use
gmpy, this is where you stop.
So that's multiplication.
So we have a bunch
of different ways
that you could do
multiplication.
What I'd like to do is give
you a sense of assuming a given
complexity of multiplication,
how long would division take?
So we are 1 and 1/2 lectures
in, and I haven't really
told you how we're going
to do division, which
is what we have to do when we
compute a divided by xi, which
is the basic integration
in the Newton method.
So let's get to that.
So finally
high-precision division.
So we want a high-precision
rep off a divided by b.
And we're going to compute
a high-precision rep
off 1 divided by b first.
And what we mean by
that is that we'll
compute r divided
by b floor where
r is a really large value.
And more importantly,
it's easy to divide
by r in a particular base.
So for example, r
equals 2 raised to k,
when we use base
2, you can easily
divide through a shift operator.
So if I give you r divided
by b and I give you
this long computer word that's
in base 2, which typically
could have millions of
digits in its representation,
I can shift that by
the appropriate amount
to a given r divided by b.
I can get 1 over b by
shifting that quantity.
So it feels like,
hey wait a minute.
Why are we dividing by r?
Well remember that
you want 1 over b.
And if you're computing
r divided by b floor,
and you actually want 1
over b, which then you
could use to multiply by a
so you can run your Newton
iteration, then you
want to divide by r.
And that division
is essentially going
to be something that
shifts things to the right.
So the most significant
bits move to the right,
and you get a smaller number.
That make sense?
So we all know how
to divide by using
shifting assuming the
bases work out right.
And if you had a representation
that was decimal,
suddenly you could certainly
divide by 10 raised to k.
That's easy.
You've done this many times.
But you just changed
the decimal point
when you're working
with decimal arithmetic.
When you divide 72 by
100 and you get 0.72.
And that's a very
similar notion here.
It doesn't really matter what
base you're talking about.
So that's the setup.
That's how are we
going to try and tackle
this division problem.
But we still have this problem
of computing r divided by b.
So how are we going to
compute r divided by b?
And we want this to be a large
number of digits of precision.
So we're going to use
Newton's method again.
You've got some non-linearity
here with respect to 1 over x.
And we're gonna use
Newton's method again.
And we'll have to hope
that this works out,
that we can get Newton's
method, it'll converge,
and it'll require operations
that we know how to do.
And all of this is going
to work out really well.
I'm going to set
up a function, f
of x equals 1 divided by
x minus b divided by r.
So what this means is
that this function has
a 0 at x equals r divided by b.
So if I try and find
the 0 of this function,
and I start out with a
decent initial guess,
I'm going to end up
with r divided by b.
And if I'm working
with integers,
effectively that's the floor
that I have for r divided by b.
And then I do my shift and
I end up with 1 over b.
So someone who remembers
differentiation,
if you're gonna apply
Newton's method,
tell me what the
derivative of f of x is.
Somebody's stretching
at the back,
but I don't think
that was an answer.
Someone at the back?
Too easy a question?
For the cushion.
AUDIENCE: 1 over
negative x squared.
PROFESSOR: 1 over
Who's that?
All right.
You can come pick this up.
Whatever.
Cut the monotony here.
Just veered to the left.
I think next time I'm going
to weight them or something.
Let's just do
frisbees next time.
It makes it easy.
Forget cushions.
No?
Frisbees or cushions?
How many want frisbees?
How many want cushions?
Frisbees win.
So you got derivative of x is
minus 1 divided by x squared.
And then if you go off and
apply Newton's method--
and I'm not going to go through
the symbolic equations here
associated with
Newton's method--
but that's basically the
same as we did before.
You are computing a tangent,
and the new value of xi plus 1
given the value of xi
is the x-intercept.
And we needed the
derivative to compute that.
But bottom line, you
have xi plus 1 equals
xi minus f of xi divided
by f prime of xi.
So that's the Newton iteration.
And it's worth plugging in
the various values here.
1 divided by xi
minus b divided by r.
That's f of x on top divided by
minus 1 divided by xi square.
So that's the
derivative over here.
So all I'm doing is
plugging things in.
But you want to visualize
this because this is really
what we need to compute.
And we have xi plus 1 equals
xi plus xi square times
1 over xi minus b divided by r.
And finally I get 2xi minus
b xi square divided by r.
That is key.
This is pretty important.
So let's us look all the
way to the left, which
is xi plus 1, all the way
to the right, 2 times xi.
That doesn't scare
us, 2 times something.
Especially base 2, pretty easy.
That's a multiply.
Multiplies don't
scare us because we
know how to do
multiplies anyway.
This is a simple multiply.
And then I got a square here.
Square.
Not a square root.
Squares don't scare us
because that's a multiply,
just multiplying the
same number to itself.
And this doesn't
scare us because we
know that we've chosen r
to be an easy division.
So all of the operations
here are either easy,
or they require a multiply.
So remember I'm going to put a
picture up towards the end here
that tells you the overall
structure for computing
square root of a or
square root of 2.
But we've just sort of sold
out to Newton, if you will.
Because we said that we're
going to use Newton's method
to compute essentially,
iteratively, square root of a.
And within the Newton
method, the first iteration,
if you will, of
the Newton method,
we had to compute a reciprocal.
We had to compute 1 over xi.
And in order to
compute 1 over xi,
we're going to apply Newton's
method again like I showed over
here and over there.
And so that division is
going to require iteration.
But the iteration at the second
level is one of multiplication.
You're gonna repeatedly
apply multiplication
because you're going
to go xi plus 1
based on xi using multiplication
and some easy operations.
And then you go xi plus 2, xi
plus 3, and so on and so forth.
That make sense?
I'll try and put this up to
give you the complete picture
once we're done talking
about the division
algorithm and its complexity.
But before I do
that, I just want
to give you a sense of the
convergence of this scheme.
Again, I want to give
you an example first,
and then I'll argue
about the convergence.
You have to run
this iteratively.
You've got to make i
to get to the point
where it's large enough that you
have your digits of precision.
And just as an
example, let's say
we want r divided by b equals
2 raised to 16 divided by 5.
So this is a fairly
straightforward example.
But when you get up to integers,
it turns out it's evocative.
So r was selected to be 2 raised
to k to make for easy division.
And what I really want is that.
And I want to see how I get
to that using Newton's method.
And our initial
guess, let's say we
try 2 raised to 16
divided by 4, because we
know how to divide
by a power of two.
And so that's 2 raised to 14.
And that's our initial guess.
So think of that as being x0.
That is x0.
And that 16384.
x1 is going to be 2 times
16384, which is exactly that,
minus 5 times
16384 whole square.
So now you're starting to
square a fairly big number.
And obviously if you'd
started with an even bigger r,
this would be a large number.
You go 65536 equals--
and this is 12288.
So you really have one
digit of precision there.
But the next time around,
you get 2 times 12288 minus 5
times 12288 square
divided by 65536.
And this division is easy.
It's a shift.
You get to 13056.
And I won't write
this whole thing out,
but if you take that, the next
thing you'll get is 13107.
So as you can see, there's
rapid convergence here.
And you can actually do a very
similar analysis to the epsilon
analysis-- and I'll
put it in the notes,
but I won't do it here-- that
I did for the square root
iteration to show that you
have a quadratic the rate
of convergence when you apply
Newton's method to division as
well.
So you can prove that using
the symbolic analysis than we
did very similar to the
epsilon n relationship
to epsilon n plus 1.
I'd suggest that it's
a difference equation
here so that analysis
is not exactly the same.
But you can run
through that, and you
can read that in the notes.
So we're in business.
Finally things are
looking up with respect
to being able to actually
implement this in practice.
I want to talk about complexity.
And I promise that there
was a subtlety associated
with the complexity of division
in relation to multiplication,
but let me just go over and
write down what I just told you
with respect to the
number of iterations
that division requires.
So division,
quadratic convergence.
So number of digits
doubles at each step.
Good news.
So d digits of precision,
log d iterations.
Now let's say that we have
a particular algorithm
for multiplication that
I'm just going to say,
since we have so many
different algorithms,
I'm going to say multiplication
in theta n raised
to alpha time, where alpha is
greater than or equal to 1.
I just want to be
general about it.
And so assuming that I have a
multiplication algorithm, that
can run in theta
n raised to alpha,
where clearly you know alpha can
be 1.46 for Toom 3, et cetera.
And it's not quite that
for Schonhage-Strassen,
but I just want to be working
with one particular complexity.
So I'll parameterize
it in this fashion.
And everything I say is going to
be true for Schonhage-Strassen
and Furer as well.
But first, easy question.
What is the
complexity of division
using the analysis that I've
put on the board so far?
n digit numbers
it's going to be?
I wanna hear from you.
How many hard
multipliers do I have?
Log of?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: Log of n, right?
It wasn't a hard question.
So division would be theta
log n times n raised to alpha.
Everybody buy that?
No?
Ask a question if
you're confused.
Maybe I should say
everybody buy that?
How many people agree with that?
Big O?
Yeah, that's right.
Big O. I'm hedging my bets here.
I'm just saying big O. I
could say big O of n cubed
and you should
all agree with me.
Or big O of whatever.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: What's the
longest [INAUDIBLE]
number of [INAUDIBLE]
we need to get
a certain level of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So if you want d
digits of precision,
then according to this
argument-- and I think you
guys are a little
doubtful here because I
kept talking about subtleties,
and in fact there's
a subtlety here, which I want
to get to-- but this big O
thing is perfectly correct.
But to answer your
question, yes.
Let's assume that it's
n digits of precision.
That's what we assume
whether it's n or d.
You can plug in the
appropriate symbol here.
And we're saying that, look,
every iteration is bounded
by n raised to alpha
complexity for the multiply.
And I'm going to do
a logarithmic number
of iterations.
So I end up getting log n
times n raised to alpha.
So that is correct, in fact.
Big O is correct.
So now it comes to the
interesting question,
which is can you do
a better analysis?
So this sort of hearkens
back to three weeks
ago, maybe you've forgotten.
Maybe you've blanked
it out of your memory,
but I thought I described
to you build max-heap.
And we had this
straightforward analysis
of build max-heap that
was n log n complexity.
And then we looked at it
a little more carefully,
and we started adding things
up much more carefully.
We turned into bank accountants.
And then we decided that
it was theta n complexity.
People remember that?
Right?
So I want you to turn
into bank accountants
again, and then tell me first,
there's a nice observation
that you can make here
that we haven't made yet
with respect to the
size of these numbers.
We know what we
want to eventually,
but there's a nice observation
we can make it with respect
to the size of these numbers.
And then we want to
exploit that observation
to do a better analysis of the
theta complexity of division.
So who wants to tell me
what the observation is.
This is definitely
worth a cushion.
What's the observation?
I want to end up with
d digits of precision.
If I give you another hint,
I'm gonna give it away.
Someone tell me.
This is a dynamic process, OK?
So what do I start with?
What do I start with?
If I want to compute
something and you
want to use Newton's method,
what do you start with?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You start with
one digit of precision.
That's fantastic.
I don't know if you already
have a cushion or not,
but here's the second one.
So you start with a small
number of digits of precision.
And then you end up with a
large million, whatever, number,
which is your d.
So what does that mean?
So now somebody take
that and run with it.
Somebody take that
and run with it.
You already have a cushion.
Like many?
You guys, usual suspects.
So someone take that
and run with it.
What can I do now?
What does it mean if I start
with a small number of digits
of precision?
My initial guess was one, right?
I mean, that had one
digit of precision.
And then the number of digits
doubles with each step.
So is there any
reason why I'm doing,
if I had d digits of
precision, eventually
that I'll have to do d digit
multiplies in each iteration?
Any reason why?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You don't have to,
because [INAUDIBLE] multiplies
are going to be trivial.
And [INAUDIBLE] then you're
going to eventually approach
the d to the alpha iteration.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Exactly right.
That's worth a cushion.
But now I want you
or someone else,
tell me what the
iteration looks like.
So this is the key observation.
The key observation is that if
I want d digits of precision,
I'm going to start with
maybe one digit of precision.
So this is d of p, or dig
of p, not to be confused.
I start with 1, 2, 4,
and I end up with d.
And our claim was that this
was log d iterations, right?
So the initial
multiplies are easy.
Initially you're
doing constant work
if you have really
small numbers associated
with these multiplies.
It's only towards the
end that you end up
doing a lot more work, right?
So someone tell me if I
have n raised to alpha,
and if I say I want
to write an equation.
And I don't want
to use theta here.
I'm going to use
constants because I
want to add up constants,
and it's a little iffy then
you add up thetas.
You need to be
looking at constants.
Now I can imagine that for this
iteration, the very first one,
that I have something like
c times 1 raised to alpha,
because it's just a
single digit of precision.
OK And the next one, I'm
using the same algorithm.
This is c times 2 raised
to alpha, c times 4
raised to alpha.
And then out here
I'm going to have
c times d by 4 raised to
alpha plus c times d by 2
raised to alpha plus finally
c times d raised to alpha.
And someone give me a bound.
Who wants to give
me a bound on this?
Less than or equal to.
Let's just make it less than.
What?
Someone?
Just plug in a value of alpha.
And remember your convergent
geometric series and things
like that.
What is that?
Someone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just some constant
times d to the alpha?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Just some constant
times d to the alpha.
And in fact, you can say,
it's 2c d to the alpha.
Keep a question for you aside.
So that' sit.
That's the little careful
analysis that we had to do,
which basically without
changing your code, really,
suddenly gave you a
better complexity.
Isn't that fun?
That's always fun.
You had this neat
algorithm to begin with.
And bottom line is you're
just computing things
a little more accurately,
than essentially saying
that you had to do
all of this work
with large number of digits of
precision at every iteration.
The number of digits
actually increases.
So what does this mean?
I guess ultimately, the
complexity of division
is now what?
It's the same as the complexity
of multiplication, right?
So regardless of whether we
did a Newton iteration or not,
the complexity of division.
You are doing a logarithmic
number of iterations,
but since eventually
all of the work
is going to get done
at the end here.
Most of the work is getting
done at the end when
you have these long numbers.
That's basically the
essence of the argument.
So let me finish up and
talk about the complexity
of computing square roots.
And as you can imagine,
even though you
have two nested Newton
iterations here,
you can make basically
the same argument.
So let's recall what
we're doing in terms
of computing square roots.
We want to compute
square root of a.
And we said, well we don't
quite know how to do this.
We're going to end up doing
10 raised to 2d times a,
and we're going to run
Newton's method on it.
So you've got one level
of Newton's method.
And the iteration here with
respect to Newton's method
is something like xi plus 1
equals xi plus a divided by xi.
Now every time you do
that for a particular xi,
you're going to end up
having to call a division.
So you're going to
call a division here,
and then you're going
to call a division here.
For each iteration you
have to call a division.
And what we're
saying is, well we're
going to end up having to call
for each of these division
methods we're going to
call Newton's method.
And what that is
something like 2xi
minus b xi square divided by r.
And that's going to be a
bunch of multiplications.
And what we argued up
until this point was
that the complexity
of the division,
even though we had a
bunch of iterations here,
a logarithmic number of
iterations, the complexity
of the division was the
same as the complexity
of the multiplication
because the numbers
started out small and grew big.
All right?
Everybody buy that?
I'm going to use exactly
the same argument
for this level of
iteration as well.
And again, when you start out
with the digits of precision
corresponding to
square root of 2,
you're going to start
out guessing 1.5,
which is your initial guess
for the square root of 2,
and it's going to be a small
number of digits of precision.
And eventually you'll
get to a million digits.
So using essentially the
same equation summing,
you can argue that the
complexity of computing
square roots is the complexity
of division, which of course is
the complexity of
multiplication.
And that's the story.
So obviously the code would
be a little more complicated
than a multiplication
code, because you
have all this control
structure outside of it.
It's really two nested loops.
The multiply is getting
called a bunch of times
to do the divide,
and the divide is
getting called a bunch of times
to compute the square root.
But ultimately, because
the numbers are growing
and you start out with small
numbers, most of the work
is done when you get to
the millions of digits
of precision.
And you basically
have theta n raised
to alpha complexity for
computing square roots.
If you have n raised
to alpha multiply,
and you want n
digits of precision.
All right?
See you next time.
Stick around for questions.